6 25 on your friday morning what's
driving you crazy well how about some
weekend ramp closures where us 95 meets
the northern 215 beltway
let's go
centennial bowling
yeah nevada department of transportation
crews they're going to be shifting
lanes to get ready for the remaining
work in the centennial project on the
east side of u.s 95 and to do that
well they're going to be a couple of
ramp closures starting sunday night at
nine
and scheduled to run until five monday
morning so we're talking about the
flyover ramp from the west 215 to go
south on the 95
also the exit ramp from the north 95 to
get down to buffalo
that ramp was actually closed last night
ended this morning as was that rank
we've been talking about north 95
to the east 215 so all of our reports
they are posted to our website
8newsnow.com you click traffic then
driving you crazy please buckle up drive
carefully
and put down that phone if there is
something driving you crazy you can
always email me traffic eight
at eightnewsnow.com